buddy and welcome to today's live
broadcast cannabis science technology
for better quality of life
presented by Russ Osmo founder of the
medical cannabis Society my name is
Patrick nightingale and I'm the
executive director of the medical
cannabis Society and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots
laborat is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box that appears on the
screen we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you're having trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the help desk button
located in the promotional board at the
bottom center of your screen or use the
ask a question box to let us know that
you're having problems now please join
me in welcoming mr. so Tassimo i will
now turn the presentation over to him
Thank You Patrick certainly cannabis
sativa a truly versatile plant helps
with a lot of things it's one of the
fastest growing plants that Mother
Nature has to offer and we have record
of it being one of the first plants to
be spun into useable fiber some 10,000
years ago the beauty of him is that it
requires no pesticides or chemicals to
grow and the growing nature of the plant
has the roots someone choking out other
weeds making it flourish and over power
is the ability for other weeds and
plants to sustain themselves allows the
hemp plant to grow freely it's much of
the reason that it's named weed hemp
itself can be refined into many things
to cover a variety of commercial uses
such as clothing biodegradable plastic
and paper which will ultimately be part
of its demise in years in the future can
also be used for buildings so for
example you could walk into a hemp house
where the frame was constructive hemp
molding the insulation of hemp fiber the
paint on the walls derived from hemp
itself
even down to the canvas paintings on the
wall which ironically canvas was named
after the word cannabis so hemp's one of
the most strongest and most durable of
all textile fibers it works great for
clothing in regards the cotton it
requires half the amount of water that
you would need to produce a field of
cotton grows very quickly and it produce
about twenty hundred two hundred fifty
percent more fiber than the same amount
of cotton in the same type of field so
hemp could be made into fuel in addition
to that not just fuel for machinery and
biofuel but human fuel and animal fuel
in fact that in its raw form hemp is one
of the most nutritionally complete foods
really on the planet and has a perfect
balance of omega-3s and omega-6s as well
as all the amino acids some 2700 years
ago 2700 BC we had word of cannabis
showing up as a medicine for the first
time at the time China was infusing it
into teas for maladies such as malaria
constipation and memory loss or early
Alzheimer's just to give you a frame of
reference in 6500 BC we started rice
cultivation in China around 5200 BC we
started to see the domestication of
chickens and then 3600 BC was the first
appearance of silk in China so 2700 BC
we started to see cannabis for medical
purposes
well 1300 years later in Egypt we
started to see Egyptians using this for
things such as glaucoma and much like
the Egyptian culture at the time they
were putting everything in the enemas
and administering it that way meanwhile
over in Italy I'm sorry in India they
were using it for leprosy and mixing it
with milk to use as an anesthetic
fast-forward to 100 BC and they finally
have on record is starting to identify
some of the psychoactive properties of
marijuana in China moving forward to
about 1200 AD we have reports of Marco
Polo reporting back to Europe about
cannabis use in the all over the world
by the 1600s cannabis made its way to
Europe and we have record
William Shakespeare going on record
saying that he was using us as a
stimulant to produce his plays in in
writings others in England reason this
is melancholy or for melancholy errs we
like to call it today depression and in
fact the tea itself was given to the
Queen of England to use for menstrual
cramps in the 1600 people started to
make their way over to the Americas
where Jamestown in 1607 was the first
permanent English settlement it was
founded by King James
they made it colony law in 1619 that all
residents were required to grow Indian
hemp and send it back to England to
support England and their cause so we
make it in the 1700s and America's star
to make their way George Washington was
growing hemp as one of his three main
crops at Mount Vernon in Virginia you
could actually be jailed for refusing to
grow I haven't been the late 60 M sorry
late 1700s cannabis was actually used to
pay taxes and back then you could use it
to barter fast-forward to 1776 July 4th
in Philadelphia our nation's founding
fathers signed a document that announced
at 13 colonies we're gonna go ahead and
separate themselves from the British
Empire and we're gonna record the regard
themselves as 13 independent sovereign
states that document was a dickerer
Declaration of Independence and that was
created out of him our founding fathers
grew it and in fact Thomas Jefferson
stated that hemp would be the cash crop
that our country would be built on going
into the 1800s as far as medicine goes
the United States was a very do yourself
type of culture you would go down to
your local apothecary and you would have
them whip up something whether it was an
oil tanker cream some sort of ointment
lozenges candies you name it they put it
together and it would help remedy your
particular ailment there was a man by
the name of Sir William O'Shaughnessy he
introduced
peuta queues of cannabis in western
medicine and was able to validate some
of the folk uses that we have seen in
India he was able to discover some of
the new applications and ultimately
recommended cannabis for a great variety
of things and I think he established his
reputation by successfully relieving the
pain of rheumatism and being able to
stop the convulsions of children so
early age epilepsy in 1950 up until the
mid 1930s cannabis was officially listed
in the United States pharmacopoeia as
working for things like gout tonsillitis
insanity alcoholism but probably a
hundred different uses it was the prime
medicine for within this pharmacopoeia
and what I want to mention here is you
look at the slide that we have that's a
picture of the Pittsburgh commercial
Gazette from the late 1800s and if you
look here there's an ad that's
identified that shows that hashish candy
from Philadelphia if you go to the next
slide here if you zoom in it says four
returned soldiers whose constitutions
have become shattered by the hardships
of the camp they may find relief in its
use when all other remedies fail for
nervousness headache low spirits cough
neuralgia loss of appetite chronic
diarrhea asthma and dissenter II it
stands unrivaled and I think it's
interesting because back then they
didn't have post-traumatic stress
disorder as we would call it today but
obviously these are the same symptoms
and they're explaining here the cannabis
obviously was unrivaled time as far as a
remedy goes so as early as 1853 we
started to see recreational cannabis
become available every major city on the
East Coast started to see these cannabis
Denton's pop up you saw a lot of the
opium dens at that time and New York
there was probably out 500 these
cannabis stems that were right next to
the opium dens
so they went hand in hand about 500
about that time in an effort to kind of
regulate where all this was going the
United States stepped up and introduced
the Pure Food and Drug Act of 1906
and it basically made it so that
anything that wasn't a standardized
medicine was considered a poison and it
basically prohibited the sale outside of
pharmacies or apothecaries wasn't really
a problem for Pharma and they jumped in
from roughly the 1900s to the 1930s
started selling cannabis extracts
over-the-counter for about a hundred
different things if you look at this
slide here we have an example of what
the early days looked like there's a
label from Eli Lilly from 1913 mecanim
is indica extract in 1930
we had a gentleman by the name of Henry
Anslinger who became the founding
commissioner of the Treasury's Federal
Bureau of Narcotics he was appointed by
his uncle Andrew Mellon who at the time
was the richest man in the world and he
was put in place to crack down on
Prohibition he was given a budget of
$100,000 and sent free unfortunately for
Anslinger prohibition ended in 1933 and
at that time alcohol was then legal and
Anslinger as the guy that was put in
place to crack down on prohibition
didn't have much to do he then decided
to start demonizing cannabis tying it to
immigrants that were coming up from
Mexico and he called it marijuana he
claimed that it caused people to commit
violent crimes and act irrationally and
overly sexual he then started producing
propaganda films to promote this and
eventually the rest of the country took
on at the time the federal government
didn't have any authority over the
states because they had implemented the
Tenth Amendment to regulate medicines
that power was only reserves I'm sorry
let's just take that back the federal
government had no authority under the
Tenth Amendment to regulate medicines
that power was reserved by individual
states in 1937 the only way to do this
was impose a federal tax so they could
legislate it so the decision of the
Congress in 1937 was that passed the
marihuana Tax Act and was based on
poorly
hearings and reports on questionable
studies all generated by Henri Anslinger
himself Henri
Harry Harry yeah you're right um
basically this made marijuana illegal
for anything outside of medical and
industrial uses and you needed to have
this tax to make it happen the American
Medical Association opposed the Act they
were claiming that cannabis was working
and there was no evidence of this being
harmful and in fact dr. William Woodford
which was a doctor a lawyer of the time
was Legislative Council for the American
Medical Association and he testified
before Congress in 1937 stating that
prohibition loses the sight of the fact
that future investigation may show that
there are substantial medical benefits
and uses for cannabis unfortunately he
went on hard Anslinger got to keep his
job
and he cracked down on marijuana across
the United States now looking back at
hemp this is late 1930s they had just
invented the core Decatur which was a
farm machine that basically gave farmers
the ability to pull the the fibers out
of hemp for the first time on a small
scale so we were able to put this on
these small farms and saved massive
amounts of labor and made hemp
production practical on a small scale so
hemp itself could be used for about five
thousand purposes and you can get three
harvests out of a single year in
February of 1938
Popular Mechanics reported that hemp was
the new billion-dollar crop and it was
dude it was entirely due to the fact
that we had this ability to mass-produce
this through the decor Decatur in 1942
we have a video here you see the slide
this is hemp for victory the film itself
was made to encourage farmers to grow
hemp for the war effort because we were
obviously short on it and the industrial
fibers were were wonderful for war
before 1989 it was it was unknown that
this film was was put out there
in fact the United States government
that you're good
Native States government wanted to let
our civilians and citizens know how to
grow hemp how its processed how it's
used for rope cloth cordage and things
of that nature that could be used for
war including fire hoses parachute
webbing canvas tow lines you name it the
United States Department of Agriculture
in the Library of Congress told all
interested parties that this movie was
never even made and it wasn't available
luckily two VHS copies were recovered
and donated to the Library of Congress
in 1989 by Mia Farrow Carl Packard and
the marijuana advocate and well-known
Jack Herer now back in the nineteen
thirty nine in 1935 or say when there
was a shortage of hemp DuPont started
working on nylon which was a synthetic
competitor was made out of rayon Andrew
Mellon who we spoke about earlier and
the uncle to Anslinger was the Secretary
of Treasury at the time and also the
wealthiest man in America he invested
heavily into DuPont and really counted
on its success of course depending on
whether hemp was gonna be short or not
see things seemed headed that way and
until 1945 the war ended properly and we
then had a surplus of him who's bad news
for mr. melon and the DuPont family
melon and LaMotta DuPont had major
financial interest in this to promote
their own products really all chemical
companies I had a problem with him
because you could grow it yourself
additionally the surplus of hemp could
crush a guy like William Randolph Hearst
who owned all of media outlets in all
the newspapers the United States was at
the point that he started to work on
yellow journalism to start and demonize
the cannabis plant and if you look at
why he was really one of the first major
special interests outside of DuPont and
the synthetic fabric industry and the
fact that he owned the media outlets he
owned the lumber mills to support the
media outlets and he also owned the
lumber fields to support the lumber
mills
in the paper production the promise of
hemp-based products was so great that
they threatened to really replace all
the petroleum-based products and
petrochemicals including synthetic
fibers in gasoline when you look at hemp
in compared to lumber one acre of hemp
can produce the same amount of plant
fiber that you would get out of four
acres of trees not to mention it takes
90 days to renew plant I happen
obviously we know trees take years if
you think this was intimidating to those
guys Mellon DuPont and Hearst you're
right there was billions of dollars at
risk to their old-school cronies and
financial backers because of him and its
new surplus at the time when you look at
Popular Mechanics magazine they boasted
that Henry Ford's first Model T was
built out of him the doors themselves
were made out of plastic the the rest of
the car was made out of hemp products as
well they were able to take a sledge
hammer and literally smack the side of
this thing without any dent to the hemp
plastic there was ten times lighter than
steel to boot ford envisioned this car
running on him by products as well fact
is that stuff threatened DuPont
and it threatened Hearst in his timber
mill and media empire if you look at the
slide here we have Henry Ford quoted as
saying why use up the forests which are
centuries in the making and the mines
which required ages to lay down if we
can get the equivalent of forests and
mineral products in the annual growth of
hemp fields to think that Henry Ford was
trying to give the world a vehicle it
was safe strong and clean didn't hurt
the environment and yet that invention
was completely suppressed by special
interest when you look at how a compiled
a kit complies with every single eco
standard that we have today in fact it
blows them all out of the water the
suppression this technology was largely
due to the fact that hemp was outlawed
in 1937 due to the potential damaging
effect that would have on many powerful
industries at the time
campus ended up being rebranded tied to
marijuana and tied to immigrants and
Anslinger Hearst DuPont and Mellon craft
a highly inflammatory anti marijuana
public relations campaign with the goal
of really making the afore herb illegal
and effectively eliminating it as a
competitor to him and all the
petrochemical products and timber for
Hearst the cultivation can't have
cannabis and hemp and that I've become
an illegal illegal in the United States
1937 it's been illegal ever since fast
forward in 1970 there's a man by the
name of Richard Nixon and grew up
watching the reefer madness campaigns on
TV he started a war on drugs and
repealed the Marijuana Act that had been
put in place some thirty three years
later they ended up implementing the
Controlled Substances Act of 1970
officially prohibiting the use of
cannabis for all purposes including
medical so since its inception in 1970
the DEA has regulated hemp in addition
under that act
so at hemp is considered a Schedule one
drug so let's talk about where we're at
now
it's 2018 nothing's changed people are
sick
you got 126 people that are going to be
diagnosed with epilepsy you have 40
percent of the people that are watching
this today that will be diagnosed with
cancer unfortunately we have 22 veterans
a day that are taking their lives most
likely due to post-traumatic stress
disorder symptoms and it's safe to say
that the entire country has a pain
problem is under an epidemic we still
have a schedule one imposition on canvas
it's keeping our researchers from being
able to touch it we still have special
interest groups big pharma is the bad
guy right now we also have big alcohol
and tobacco that don't like the fact
that cannabis is making its way into our
country the pharmaceutical industry is
profiting from pain in the opioid
epidemic they don't want to give up
their profits cannabis poses a major
threat to these industries they don't
want a whirl with legalized cannabis
and they're making it really impossible
for us when you look at what cannabis is
doing for really people with pain in
states where they have legalized
cannabis we see now up to a 77 percent
decrease in opioid overdose deaths
that's the kind of data we have to work
with which is extremely limited in
general but this is the kind of stuff
that can pharmaceutical industry doesn't
want to see what do we know we know that
cannabis is effective we know that it
works we know it's working for cancer
PTSD pain but the data we have to prove
it's extremely limited in currently
anecdotal the underlying problem still
is that we have a Schedule one
restriction on the research of cannabis
even researchers with DEA approval or
having a hard time getting their hands
on this for instance dr. sue Sisley
when you ask sue what her problem is
it's not that she can't access it or get
the approval by the FDA it's that she
can't find veterans to do the research
because the VA can't get behind this
because of its schedule one restrictions
now we look at Johns Hopkins when you
talk to them they tell us that they can
get access to it although getting to
that point we have to jump through hoops
and when they finally do it's access to
one single strain from the University of
Mississippi that's grown outdoors part
of the federal program it's limited and
it's it's well it's one single strange
not much you could do with it one of the
major problems is because of this we
don't have any data our scientists of
researchers can't do what they do best
they can't access the plan the
information within the plan like they
could any other medicine let's look at
an example California has had the
ability for people to medically apps to
access this stuff for about twenty years
when you look at an example here from
Beth she's a 73 year old that was
visiting the dispensary for the second
time in California to try and find a
remedy for her rheumatoid arthritis she
says specifically the search could be
complicated and frustrating I don't want
to get high I just want to be able to
get out of pain if this doesn't work I'm
through
so if we know canvas works for pain why
is Beth frustrated well she's frustrated
because we have data such as what you
see on Leafly it says blue DreamWorks
for pain or for sleep might stimulate
you it's all over the place it's very
limited as though we have this current
point something like blue dream may be
different Philadelphia as it is in
California because we have strange rift
and harvesting times that are different
and so on and so forth it's not what our
doctors are looking for we're still in
the dark they've literally been exposed
to just the tip of the iceberg there's a
whole heck of a lot of stuff on that
surface that we don't know safe to say
that we're in the dark we definitely
haven't made it very far in 100 years
people are finding relief yeah we
haven't scratched the surface as to
what's really helping safe to say that
William o Shaughnessy from the 1850s had
more freedom to operate and most likely
knew more about the effects of cannabis
cannabis and the benefits and therapies
that could be used he knew more than we
didn't then when we do in 19 or 2018
let's just look at some of the
technology that's evolved over the last
hundred years so here we see the
invention of the telephone
Alexander Graham Bell nowadays you could
hold a phone in the pocket of your pipe
your pants everybody nightstand everyone
in the world has one in fact we have
more cell phones than people let's look
at the grammar phone when people wanted
that listen to music at home you took a
record phonograph and you played it at
home nowadays you have every song known
to man in the pocket in your phone here
we see a TV from 1930s in the right hand
in his right hand he's hold a cathode
ray tube and the TV is about the same
size as the man in it now fast-forward
to today and we see Steve Jobs holding
an iPad in his hand he holds not only an
iPad but every TV every TV show
I'm sorry every TV show every movie
every song that he needs and he wants to
listen to right there
so just one last drafts comparison on
the right side you see a child in 2018
holding a phone but includes internet TV
a thing called email it's something else
called video games all in the palm of
his hand on the other side you see a
child in 1930 holding a knob it's gonna
give him about 3 different channels I
think you get the drift what do we do we
know it's working
we know what's working for cancer
epilepsy PTSD autism pain things of that
nature we know it works more generally
for relaxation and wake you up
you know stimulate your appetite it'll
relax you
we know it's safe we know that there are
no records of anyone dying from taking
cannabis we know it's non-toxic you know
we work with these caretakers we see the
toxic soup of narcotics that these
children are on and a lot of times they
get lost in the soup this is a non-toxic
version that these parents are happy to
see and give their kids eventually it
helps them lean off and cut down on the
suffering we know we're on to something
in 2003 the United States and the
Department of Health became the first
assignee to patent cannabinoid contact
cannabinoid compounds as an antioxidant
and neuro protective although this
research is a breakthrough we're still
limited and our researchers can't touch
it because this scheduled one in
position but yet we know it works when
you look at a guy by the name of dr.
Sanjay Gupta he was public about
opposing marijuana after he looked under
as many rocks as he could he went back
publicly and said that he completely
changed his point of view and that he
believes that we've been systematically
and terribly misled in the United States
for over 70 years I have to say I agree
with him safe to say that our research
and scientists have been handcuffed and
really handcuffed for about a hundred
years because of this it's kept our
physicians in the dark and ultimately
hurt patients
well one by one the states are starting
to come back right now we have 29 states
that have legalized cannabis in one way
or another and it's safe to say that we
have collectively reached a tipping
point start to take control back
technologies advanced to the point that
it's going to help us grab data out of
that plant and give our researchers the
ability to do what they do best data
that's going to provide us knowledge and
insight that of the variety to our
regulators data for our researchers and
data for our physicians data so that we
can start to take action its 2018 the
technology's here the science is here
the networks finally in place we have
the ability to communicate all over the
world through the use of the internet
and share information now is the time
for science medicine and technology to
come together and finally break the
chains that have been imposed on
researchers for the last hundred years
we still know that there are some
problems for instance we still have
special interest groups that are
fighting a lot of the world still has
that reefer madness mentality we still
have our Anslinger because of this
cannabis still remains a Schedule one
narcotic we don't see it being
rescheduled anytime soon currently the
industry has been growing up to do with
products being mislabeled we have an
issue with standardization it's been the
ongoing issue since 1906 in this country
remains an issue today our physicians
want to see standardized medicine they
want to be able to repeat treatment know
that they're doing the best for that
patient we need to create methods for
standardization of qualities so that the
pain is the the products that we're
given the patients are safe and they're
consistent for the physicians that want
to be able to consistently dose the same
over and over again and provide relief
without fear of misleading a patient you
know there used to have an ax form soup
or up come in and tell them that lipitor
is gonna work in this many cases and
it's also maybe gonna hurt this many
people but at least someone did the
research
someone proved that it's gonna work
without access to standardized data and
information our researchers and
physicians will remain in the dark so
let's face it for the last hundred years
this plant has been demonized it's been
pretty rough on the species in general
but the tides have finally turned
science technology they're gonna help us
drive research and create better
medicines for patients manufacturing and
extraction technology is going to enable
us to fractionate isolate and
reconstitute products into standardized
medicine there may be pharmaceutical
grade targeted so we can start to
mitigate side-effects and really dig
down and make effective medicines for
our patients adequate testing and
analysis is finally available so we can
certify that our patients are ingesting
safe products that meet medical grade
standards and finally finally we have
technology that can produce qualitative
and quantitative information for our
researchers so they can effectively
measure results improve medical cannabis
efficacy once and for all so today we're
gonna hear from mothers and advocates
that took it to their state to their
legislators and pushed for reform for
hopes for a better chance and better
therapies for their children we're gonna
listen to top medical professionals who
have first-hand experience utilizing
cannabis as a patient therapy or speak
with scientific minds that are working
diligently to further studies and gather
scientific data and finally we're
speaking with researchers that can and
will identify disease targeted therapies
the work from those that will follow
will uncover truths that will help
change medicine as we see it ultimately
better medicines are going to give us a
better quality of life together we're
going to be able to cut down the fact
that 22 veterans a day take their life
we're gonna be able to improve on the
lives of those affected with epilepsy
autism cancer and about a hundred other
illnesses and we're gonna be able to
fight and hopefully effectively wipe out
the pain epidemic it's safe to say that
the group you will be hearing from over
the next two days will go down as hit in
history as pioneer and cannabis research
and will forever improve the quality of
life of future generations to come thank
you thank you mr. Joe Zasa
for that informative presentation we
will now start the live Q&A portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click the send button
will answer as many of your questions as
we have time for now let's get started
our first question is mr. Saur Saur
small the momentum of medical and
recreational cannabis reform seems
unstoppable in the United States with
2/3 of Americans having access to legal
cannabis have we won well I think I mean
I think it's safe to say the tipping
points been reached I think one of the
biggest problems in any way you talk
about recreation a little bit in there
but let's go back and just talk about
medical I I find it hard to believe that
they're gonna be able to close Pandora's
box at this point we know that it's
working we see that it's working for
children and cancer and pain and all
these things and I just don't see the
administration reversing that portion of
it with Jeff Sessions you know I don't
know what his deal is with recreational
but I I think it's gonna be tough um
thank you we have another question that
came in you talked about the the limit
on researchers being able to access the
plant material how can our researchers
and our medical professionals and our
scientists expand their body of
knowledge about the amazing potential of
cannabis sativa and cannabis ruderalis
well let's talk about you know why
there's a problem they can't get their
hands on the plant to touch it because
of the Schedule one restriction so I
think you know where we're headed with
it is we're starting to see and you're
gonna hear over the next couple days
some of the scientists and researchers
and technologists that are in the
industry they're building machinery and
technology that's gonna enable these
researchers to start to really dig down
deep into that plan and see what's
working and tie it to patient based
therapies and start to look at how that
patient you know things are turning out
for patients yes so hopefully answers
that question yeah and I think we have
time for one more question and this goes
back to the domestic hemp industry that
you touched on earlier as the domestic
hemp industry takes root so to speak how
does the future of the industry look
today I think I could probably just take
one simple example you could build a
house out of hemp fiber in two weeks
without the use of any tools you'd
simply use four
so I just think the the benefits the
uses and the the capabilities of hemp
not only as a textile and a building
material but food and just health in
general it's really a perfect plant and
it's something that you know luckily
this this good earth gave us thousands
of years ago so I think what's coming
from hemp is gonna be exciting just like
our founding father said it will be the
cash crop that are in our countries
don't you know if I can add just one
little point about the the future of the
hemp industry
the DEA considers hemp to be a schedule
1 controlled substance that considers
anything extracted from hemp such as
cannabidiol to be Schedule one hemp is
not permitted as far as the DEA is
concerned to be to be grown there is
recent litigation by the hemp industry
association against the DEA setting
forth that the farm bill allows for the
commercial cultivation and production of
hemp based products and that the DEA is
overstepping its regulatory authority by
attempting to schedule anything cannabis
ruderalis as Schedule one there was an
amicus brief filed by the legislators
themselves led by rand paul who
sponsored the legislation and they said
DEA this is what we intended we did not
intend to allow you to schedule this you
are overstepping your regulatory
authority oral arguments were heard in
that case a couple of weeks ago and I
think that the DEA will finally get
slapped on the nose and the result will
be the future of this expanding hemp
industry well said I would like to thank
Russ I'd like to thank you once again
for your presentation and I would also
like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for an on-demand viewing for three
months from today's date in 2018 you
will receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again have a
great day